The joe rogan experience.
I asked us historian and my podcast if
they were really that bad and he spent
his life studying the Mongols.
I said,
no,
they really that bad.
And he said,
yeah,
they were really,
there is no,
well there were Great Wall of China.
The Great Wall of China was
built to keep the Mongols out.
And uh,
if you go there now,
I was just,
I just got back from China on Monday.
I went to the Great
Wall like two weeks ago,
but the first time I went to the
Great Wall was about 12 years ago.
And,
uh,
there's Mongolian people
hang out on the top,
just a few of them that are like selling
things like woman selling postcards and
cheap stuff.
And uh,
I bought some postcards.
It was like a dollar.
I gave the woman a 10.
She wouldn't give me the change.
Uh,
so it's,
you know,
the change,
they might,
uh,
be rotten people historically,
but I also want to remind you that
they'll cheat yet the Great Wall,
Tom,
that's outrageous.
So she wouldn't eat the Great Wall.
She wouldn't give you change.
How did that go down?
Uh,
you know,
good friend,
good friends,
you know,
it was just fun to keep the money.
It was awkward.
Yeah.
Friends.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Good for interested friend.
Uh,
I would just set the Great Wall.
And again,
did you get your money?
Uh,
I didn't.
They,
they,
there was a few.
They're selling like cokes
and some different trinkets.
I didn't,
uh,
I didn't fall for it this time.
It's crazy at the wall.
I never got it back.
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
I have a detailed questionnaire at the
Great Wall is a twosie Kangan he had my
friend,
my good friend.
I got a video on Youtube,
uh,
Beijing,
Tom Rhodes,
and it's on there.
I had my camera running.
Oh,
you could see the woman as a
woman and giving me the change.
It's just so,
it's in my little Beijing video.
And what's the title again?
It's Tom Rhodes,
Beijing.
Uh,
and Wa.
And what's in that video
also is the greatest thing.
As great as the Great Wall is,
there is a Toboggan
slide that you'd go down.
It's a little,
you get it.
Sit on like a little luge plastic thing
and you've got to stick between your
legs and you push it forward to go fast
and pull it back to slow down and it's
windy and it's got some huge drops in it.
And I went there.
I don't remember that.
Damn.
There's three,
there's three sections.
This tourists can go to the Great Wall
and there's only the one section that has
this fantastic,
magnificent slide,
right?
And it's thrilling.
And then you get down to the
bottom and there's a big,
it's on that Beijing video.
I filmed it while I did it.
I just did it again a few
weeks ago and at the bottom,
uh,
are there,
it is exactly.
Uh,
there's some Chinese soldier,
communist guys with like military jackets
on down at the bottom on these big
turns going slow down,
slow down or move because obviously
they've had a few people like fly all flip
off the corners.
Oh my God.
And you good.
How are you slowing down?
How do you slow it down?
What you just,
you pull the stick towards you.
Oh my God.
And I did it.
I wouldn't see that was in
winter when I first went,
but I just did it again,
man.
It's,
it's,
I wanted to go right back up to the top.
That's great.
It's a Great Wall is,
I think that slide is even cooler and
that's so avoid the Mongols at the top.
I want to see the Mongol footage.
I want to see that broader thing.
The only manmade structure,
from what I understand
that you can see fairly.
That's horse shit.
I said that to where it is.
Here it is.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
There's some Mongolia.
Peachy.
You look at [inaudible]
with the snow on it.
Okay.
10 cars.
Alango oh,
oh $1 or two per,
we're talking dog shit.
All right.
How much is a,
what's that?
10.
10 yeah.
Good change.
Okay.
When you do that,
uh,
yeah.
Where's my chain?
Let's go.
No,
no,
10 10 sorry.
Can we all one one thing?
No,
one 10
the Great Wall.
Give me one of them.
Okay,
and then where are you?
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Sounds to me like you asked her a 10
I gave her 10 it was a dollar for the
postcards,
right?
Yeah.
10 Oh,
okay.
Well very good.
Well,
if you go back,
I think it was a miscommunication.
No,
she thought you were paying 10 bucks.
That's what it sounded like to me.
Then cars fully.
What was how I trust on
dollar and get it all right.
How much is 10 10 yeah.
10 10 yeah.
The change.
Change.
Okay.
Okay,
so she didn't change.
She did say change.
I change.
What can we all a one time change?
She's pushy to look at her.
She's Kinda like,
she slapped you.
She's every bit as you are by the way,
and then where are you
should probably eat you.
Yeah.
No one's around.
I guess I just spent three weeks
in China and she probably wouldn't
eat.
You look the by drink my
horses gave you that too.
Is that the compensation?
That was it.
Yeah.
That's actually not bad deal.
That wasn't a bad.
Got a cold metal dude.
You won.
You won the bronze.
Exactly.
I just got back from China on Monday.
And it's,
I have to say,
the nice thing about our country
is the price is the price.
You don't have to,
how much is this a 200 are you kidding me?
That's,
you know,
they'll give you like the highest price.
You want to buy something and you know,
it's only a couple dollars.
And you say,
how much is that $80 Turkey Turkey was,
there's no way that that can
be $80 and then you get home,
you're like halfway.
Why don't you just tell me what you need?
Yeah,
this is all I want to hear
Tom Rhodes to tell a story,
please.
So I was just in Hong Kong
a few weeks ago and uh,
I remembered this story of something
that happened to me the very first time I
went to Hong Kong was like 12 years ago.
And I'd never been to Hong Kong
and China and I was really excited.
And one of the it,
I was staying at the Shangri la hotel,
the most opulent,
fancy,
luxurious hotel I've ever been in my life.
I mean above,
beyond Fivestars,
just swank.
And so the first day I just walked and
walked and I'm wanting to soak a as much
of Hong Kong and my eyeballs.
I could and just see the
city and I'm walking around.
And when I got back to my hotel
room at the end of the day,
they had put a goldfish in a little
goldfish bowl on my desk and it had a note
and it said,
traveling is sacred,
but no one deserves to be alone.
That's why we've provided the goldfish.
That's awesome to be your friend and
keep you company during your stay here.
Thank you.
So two nights later,
Fatboy slim is doing a concert on
the Calhoun side of the harbor.
I love Fatboy slim.
I'd never seen him.
I had a,
you know,
somehow,
uh,
got some ecstasy or whatever it was.
And uh,
it,
it was,
it was such a great night.
These Chinese people were just
so stylish and fashionable.
It was,
I had fallen out of fashion magazines.
I just had such a great time
dancing in the middle and a fat boy,
slim was just electrifying.
That night I drank tons and I got really,
really drunk,
you know,
life of a cow.
Uh,
that night when I'm sleeping
back in my hotel room,
I shit the bed.
I'm like a half awake,
you know,
that kind of a wet or drunk sleep.
And I thought it was a Fart,
you know?
And I look,
I blow it out and it's like a
wet ass p goes all over the bed.
And I had never had,
never should have been before.
I'd never should have better
my welcome to the team.
Absolutely say I was absolutely
ashamed that it happened.
I felt terrible.
So the next day I went and
I walked all over the city,
you know,
uh,
when I came back to my hotel room,
they had taken my goldfish away.
You need to go above and rolling
deserves to be alone except for you.
You've been shitting.
You agree?
Bad,
bad shit.
X Freak.
That's the problem with ecstasy.
Sexy until you ship.
Such as the lovely thing.
They put a little goldfish in my room.
That's nice,
man.
Beautiful.
Yeah.